the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
now before i get into this video there
is something i want to say first
i just want to thank everyone for
showing some love on my most recent
video
i am writing my own version of game of
thrones season 9.
and so far i've only released the first
episode but the feedback has been
amazing
i should have known most of you would
stand behind me and show some love for
the videos but you never really know
when you're making something like this
as you all know the final season of game
of thrones was so divisive
i wasn't sure what you would say about
me wanting to make another one
attempting to fix all those mistakes
while also writing a cohesive story
that's interesting or entertaining is a
lot of work
but getting that kind of feedback makes
it all worth it
so i just wanted to say thank you for
that and also let you know i am working
on the next episode
now let's get into this video well my
friends it looks like we might finally
know what other shows
hbo has in development i know this is
something i have wanted answered
ever since it was first announced
several years ago when game of thrones
was still on the air
hbo announced they were in the early
stages of developing five different
shows set within george rr martin's
amazing universe
we knew they were initially making a new
show about the long night
it was said that this show would dive a
little deeper into the white walker's
origin
however it was shut down before it ever
really got off the ground
then they said they were making a series
about the dance of dragons when house
targaryen fought each other over the
iron throne
that show is still in development as we
speak in fact they will begin filming
for that series very soon
all of you know this already what we
didn't know was what the other shows
were about
there was a lot of speculation but
nothing was ever officially confirmed as
far as i know
now besides the other three shows i will
be discussing in this video
hbo is also considering making shows
about robert's rebellion
and dunkin egg i thought this was
interesting because george rr martin has
said
he's not interested in making a series
about robert's rebellion or duncan egg
at least not yet i have made some videos
on this already
now we have even more information that
might reveal what those other three
shows are
before i read the article i have to let
all of you know as of right now
this has not been confirmed by hbo they
have not given their own official
statement yet
but the source of this information has
been credible before
this certainly would not be the first
time they broke news surrounding game of
thrones
so let me show you what was said the
headline reads
hbo is developing three more game of
thrones spin-offs which are
nymeria flea bottom and the sea snake
hbo has more game of thrones successor
shows in the works
including one from rome creator bruno
heller and another one about the
legendary founder of
dorne the network has three additional
ideas in the works based on author
george r martin's fantasy series the
hollywood reporter has confirmed
now keep in mind they say it has been
confirmed but hbo still hasn't said
anything themselves
one of the ideas for a show has the
working title nine voyages
which is from the creator of rome bruno
heller and follows lord corliss velaryon
aka the sea snake who is the head of
house velaryon
the character also appears in the
upcoming green light game of thrones
series house of the dragon
hbo has hired actor steve tucson for
this role
most of you should know this already as
well because i have made videos on some
of the main characters from house of the
dragon
so this effort represents a spin-off of
a character from a series that hasn't
yet been shot
let alone aired now the fact that they
have already brought in a showrunner
from another hbo series should mean they
are strongly considering making this a
show
if they haven't fully decided already
since this series is named nine voyages
at least as of right now makes it sound
like we would follow corliss velaryon as
he went gallivanting around the globe
if hbo is looking for some diversity
with its cast this certainly sounds like
it would be the show
since the sea snake will be all over
essos we should meet a lot of
interesting characters from foreign
lands along the way
now as much as i love everything
happening in westeros i would also love
watching a show that did explore all the
different lands george r martin
and a song of ice and fire has to offer
as you all know
a song of ice and fire has a very
expansive universe that hbo hasn't
really delved into yet
i for one am looking forward to see
where this goes as always i will keep
you up to date with any and all
information surrounding game of thrones
and or a song of ice and fire the second
series in development has the working
title of ten thousand ships revolving
around the warrior queen princess
nymeria
a revered ancestor of house martell who
founded the kingdom of dorne
she became so legendary in the realm
that other characters within the story
bore her name
her story is set roughly 1000 years
before the events in game of thrones
making it much older on the westeros
timeline than any of the other shows
they have announced in the works
besides the series about the long night
but like i've said before
the long night is no longer getting made
into a show
also game of thrones added a storyline
involving dorne
midway through the series that fans felt
struggled to feel like an
organic aspect of the show if they give
this show the green light
the nymeria series could give an
entirely new and redemptive take on
sunspear
this could also be another show that has
a very diverse cast
but also have a female lead for its main
character
this is the direction hbo wants to head
in whether everyone likes it or not
this goes for a lot of the other
networks and studios out there as well
thankfully george r martin has created
amazing characters so i am
interested in watching just about
anything set within the universe
all i ask is for it to be a great show
hbo has to make sure that whatever
direction they do decide to go in
they must have their writers stick to
the source material
alright now for the third show it is set
in the notorious king's landing slum of
flea bottom
the maze of streets and back alleys in
the capital city where characters like
davos seaworth
and gendry baratheon were born now there
really isn't any other information about
this show
i have no idea who their lead character
would be or what the series would focus
on as its main storyline
hopefully more information will be
released soon these three ideas are in
addition to the upcoming greenlit series
house of the dragon
which begins filming in the uk in april
and stars olivia cook
matt smith along with many others house
of the dragon follows the story of house
targaryen 300 years before the events in
game of thrones and builds to an epic
civil war that ripped apart westeros
the series is from co-showrunners miguel
sapochnick and ryan condell is expected
to release next year
like i have said before another series
that may be in development
is based on george rr martin's dunkin
egg novella
it follows the adventures of the hedge
knight sir duncan
and his squire egg who would later
become king aegon targaryen the fifth of
his name
the recent influx of all these new ideas
is hbo's way of capitalizing on the
success of game of thrones
they know there is still a massive fan
base out there waiting for something new
and hopefully refreshing now casey bloys
who is an executive at hbo has said
the way we try to approach it is not by
saying we need five shows within three
years
but what are the stories worth
developing into something fans would
want to see on their screen
we have been developing multiple ideas
on different worlds
the one i want to do is the one that i
think is best creatively
i prefer to make it about the stories
and the showrunners and their vision
as opposed to hitting some arbitrary
target for the right number of shows
so this is what new information we have
as of right now
i hope all of you are seeing the writing
on the wall game of thrones
and a song of ice and fire is here to
stay hbo has several opportunities to
rebuild what they once had
now some fans will never forgive them
for what they let happen to the original
show
i understand that to some extent but
they are just getting started with this
universe
it's becoming obvious they want viewers
in westeros and
essos for the foreseeable future and
that makes me happy as a fan
like i have said before let's just hope
they learn from their mistakes
hopefully hbo will release their own
official statement soon
if i find out anything else i will let
you know right away
until then i will get back to working on
my own version of game of thrones season
9.
i hope i will see all of you back here
for that video
either way have a great day and thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you